there. Almost was the complete
story. Even just the, let's go
from the gray walking away,
everything. They were faced
with no Ramsey. No Higby. No
Darryl Henderson know, Rob
Haven Stein, the right tackle. I
mean,
that's some tough hits to take
right before that game. Would
you think of the way that the
Rams responded on the football
field?
The Rams mindset was completely
different. It was more
physical, you look at what they
did all fensively, they came
out with six offensive lineman
at times and Sean McVeigh here.
Understands, now that you can't
reach a Super Bowl with this
finesse stuff. You got to be
able to get it down there, run
the football add
extra lime. And if you have to
and on the defensive side of the
ball,
there were physical flying
around. Aaron, Donald did his
thing, but Sean make they
finally gets it. That's why
you're so pumped up because it's
like my team finally
played physical and I thought he
had a great game plan.
And also you're starting to see
Odell Beckham jr.
Come into this fold and I think
it's the perfect style of
coaching from Sha McVeigh. I
have, you saw that clip sort of
go viral last week of McVeigh
and Jefferson the way. He was
coaching him on the sidelines.
He just has this love and
appreciation for his players,
makes everybody feel that love.
And I think Odell Beckham jr.
Is, come in with a team first
bind set and Stafford's been the
right quarterback for him.
It's not like they're trying to
force him, his touches. They're
just coming within the offense,
which seems to be the
Figure a way to get obj going in
last night. He looked fast. He
looked quick. He looked
explosive. Yeah, we haven't
really seen that. After all of
these injuries that he suffered.
Absolutely, and I was about to
say the same thing. He looked
fresh. He looked free. He looked
like he was excited
about playing football. I
remember talking to him earlier
this year when we were in
Atlanta and he didn't seem
really excited. You know, he
seemed down, he seemed like he
was doubting himself, but
now he's playing with a lot more
confidence.
He's a legitimate weapon and if
you know and what happens with
cooper cooper cut they're using
him and that's one of my
concerns how much they're using
Cooper cup. And I would say,
maybe rotate,
you know, Odell Beckham in that
slot a little bit because he's
played in that. Lot, and he's
very effective when he when
he's in there.
It was cool to see Sony Michelle
out there getting
getting you know the bulk of
this workload to so many
Michelle runs hard. He's a
physical running back. Then you
get her some back. Then he got
the combination of both of
those. Guys
want to flip it to Arizona
quickly.
Kyler. Murray has played
basically his to worse games in
Primetime, the Thursday night
game where they lost to Green
Bay. Now, he comes back on
Monday night losses, to
the Rams who were without a
whole bunch of players.
Kyler Murray's performance.
Overall. What did you see from
him?
Man, I just you know, when you
watch calamari, he's a really
good player obviously and he can
he could put a lot of
pressure on the defense, but it
can't be one of those
situations Jack where he's
dropping back and he's running
around trying to create plays,
you know, and that's, that's
the thing that throws me off
when he's when he drops
back, 45 yards and he throws the
ball. I really like that.
But once he starts running
around and, you know, trying to
create all these different
plays, that's where I get
concerned. Yes, you're going to
have plays where it's
unbelievable. We say, oh my God.
Can
you believe that play that
column?
We met but there's going to be
other instances. When he's
a Young quarterback. He's going
to force the ball like he did
and throw a couple
interceptions. You can't have
that. I told you last week. I
said it comes down to his
speed, being able to
control his speed and also his
decision-making, and he has to
be better. I'm gonna tell you
one guy that I was really,
really excited to see. And that
was
James. Conner, James Conner,
he's gone through when he was
with Pittsburgh. He went through
a lot of adversity,
with all the different injuries,
and it was just
really good to see him back plan
because I died was one of
those guys that
I doubted them like mannequins,
James Conner, still play, but
now he looks faster. He looks
stronger. He looks like he's
a receiver, catching one hand
passes. Now. You can take him
out of the backfield. You could
put him in the slot or you can
bring him
out of the backfield and he can
catch the ball. We know how
tough and physical. He is as a
runner. I'm just so happy and
excited for James, Conner.
Yeah, I am right there with you.
I couldn't believe that he
was running the full route tree.
I mean, he's lining up
there in the slot and he's
running every route zigs ends
outs come back. She's down the
field 10 yards to getting
the football and
that way nine catches for 94
yards is what he finished
the game with. But probably the
biggest thing when you watch
him play is that he doesn't go
down with one guy. It takes two
or three hats around the
football.
If you're going to get him down
and it's a contract year for
him, you know, just sign that
one-year deal. They're in
Arizona, still having to prove
it even The success that he had
in Pittsburgh.
And I think he has proven
something here, Rowdy, you
think a team, a take a chance
and sign him to a couple of
years on a contract here and
give them a chance to be
the featured, Man, based on what
you're seeing.
What,
well, better be Arizona. That's
where you want to go. And
sometimes a change of scenery
environment is good and we see
it. This is a perfect fit
because he's one of those guys,
he doesn't care. He's an
Ultimate Team player.
He doesn't care, if he gets the
ball two times, or if he gets
a 25 times, he's going to do
anything. It takes to You know,
be productive for the team. I
like this kid, man. Really
excited for him.
I do to AJ, Green had a big game
for them as well over 100
yards, but I thought the biggest
thing watching this
game was that this, this Rams
defensive line. This Rams pass
rush is overwhelming, and we
knew it would take a little bit
of time for Von Miller,
for Aaron Donald to develop the
chemistry one sort of from
the inside one coming around the
outside, but that chemistry is
starting to form now. And these
are some pure athletes that are
rushing guys, like Kyler Murray
and we've seen Kyler Murray
escape and beat linebackers and
even beat defensive backs
at times with Speed, but
athletes, like Donald, and like
Von Miller are a whole different
level. We saw that
play itself out. This is the
best pass rush in all of
football.
And they took over this game
early
often, and even late, when they
need two big moments, tip
passes. You name it, whatever
they needed. This defensive
line was coming up with it.
You have a lot of times to even
if it's not the sack, it's
the pressure because he sees
those guys
trust me. He knows what number
99 is that, he knows where
number 40 is that he knows where
linear, Florida, is at,
and these guys are fast. They're
all fast. They're all
long and athletic, and they get
after you
Aaron Aaron Donna, what I mean?
What can you say, baby? We
talked about Michael Parsons and
but this guy, man, he's
still the best defensive player.
I've seen in my
generation.